huh well
no matter what work i'm trying to get
done doctor who news seems to find me so
we now have uh a very cryptic tweet from
russell t davies an announcement of neil
patrick harris appearing in the 60th and
an image but no character name now the
tweet that russell put up it's
vague and honestly i'm hesitant to put
any more meaning into it than signifying
the diamond anniversary which is the
60th anniversary maybe there's an
alternate meaning to it but let's be
honest i'm not great at speculation
which is why this is going up as a short
not a full video as far as neil patrick
harris goes it's less surprising when
you remember that he appeared in it's a
sin which was one of rtd's more recent
projects so that tracks a little bit
better i think the strongest speculation
i've seen on who he's playing is the
celestial toy maker which i could buy
and would be an interesting poll to
bring back he did get a mention uh
during whitaker's era so you know
maybe it's time